should we ban Grand Theft Auto 6 the
trailer just dropped and the new game
looks amazing the content seems very
realistic and includes casual crime
visits to strip clubs evading the cops
and tons and tons of carjackings but
none of it is real it's just a video
game yet every time a violent game is
released Busy Bodies fret about it
internet commentator Tristan Tate says
kids shouldn't play GTA Jackson Hinkle
wants to ban it and US politicians have
repeatedly introduced legislation to do
just that bad news guys violent and
sexual video games are protected by the
First Amendment a 2011 Supreme Court
case conservative Justice anonin Scalia
explicitly ruled that games are a form
of speech like books works of art and
film and governments can't suppress them
for would be censors that was game over